Matthew Perry hopes that his friend's
Legacy wouldn't be the main thing people
remembered about him and his final
interviews hold some haunting insights
into why that was the case people around
the world were shocked and heartbroken
to learn that friend star Matthew Perry
had died at the age of 54 on Saturday
October 28th in the day since social
media has been flooded with touching
tributes to Perry some of which have
been written by his colleagues and those
who knew him others of which have been
written simply by fans of his work
what's been truly incredible though is
that Perry's iconic performance as
Chandler Bing on Friends hasn't been the
main focus of many of the tributes to
him instead many have gone out of their
way to acknowledge his real life
struggles with addiction and honor how
candidly he spoke about his life in his
final years people have partly been able
to do so because of the interviews that
Perry gave during the 2022 press tour
for his Memoir friends lovers and the
big terrible thing while promoting that
book Perry spoke with astonishing
frankness and bravery about his
difficult Journey towards sobriety
reflecting on the ups and downs of his
life and offering advice to anyone else
who might have ever felt lost or
hopeless Matthew Perry's press tour for
friends lovers and the big terrible
thing was defined by the actors and
flinching honesty in a sitdown he did
for McMillan imprint flat eye and books
to promote his Memoir he got especially
candid about his beliefs that positive
change can come to anyone regardless of
their circumstances there's a very
famous kind of line that people don't
change I happen to know that people do
change and I see that every day the
moving contemplative cander of that
interview was present in many of the
final public comments that Perry made
prior to his death in an interview with
people Perry explains why he hoped to
use his sobriety as an Avenue to help
anyone who might be struggling with the
same issues he did and why he waited as
long as he did saying I had to wait
until I was pretty safely sober and away
from the active disease of alcoholism
and addiction to write it all down the
main thing was I was pretty certain
certain that it would help people the
actor brought not only real frankness to
his later years but also a level of
hardfought wisdom that made the way to
his struggles just as apparent as the
impressiveness of his personal victories
dur an appearance on Real Time with Bill
Mah Perry further reflected on his life
reality is an acquired taste that's what
I believe I have had a great deal of
time a great deal of problems acquiring
it it takes real courage for someone as
welln as Perry to be as Frank about his
personal struggles the actor was in many
of his last interviews the former friend
star even went so far as to admit that
it come to view his personal highs more
funly than any of his professional
accomplishments he didn't expect that to
ever be the case either what may have
been Perry's final interview he recalled
during a December 2022 appearance on the
Jennifer Hudson show that as a young man
he was driven by Fame he went on to say
about 3 weeks later I got friends but
God did not forget the other part and
gave me a lot of tough stuff in my life
that's how I realized that the outside
stuff doesn't really matter being famous
doesn't really matter I said God you can
do anything you want to me just please
make me famous in the wake of that
powerful realization Perry revealed that
he didn't want anyone to remember him
best as an actor but as a Survivor and
Ally to others who have struggled with
addiction he had also said that during
yet another candid conversation in
November 2022 on Q with Tom power saying
the best thing about me bar nun is if
someone comes up to me and says I can't
stop drinking can you help me I can say
yes and follow up and do it when I die I
don't want friends to be the first thing
that's mentioned I want that to be the
first thing that's mentioned and I'm
going to live the rest of my life
proving that these are heartbreaking
words to hear now but it looks like
Perry built exactly the Legacy for
himself that he wanted if you or anyone
you know needs help with addiction
issues help is available visit the
Substance Abuse and Mental Health
Services Administration website or
contact samsa's National helpline that's
1800 662 help